Everyone talks about how amazing the human
brain is, but you know what gets no credit?
The spine.
C’mon spine, show some backbone!
Hey there my veritable vertebrates, Julian
here for DNews.
We’ve talked a lot on this show about how
the human brain is incredible, It’s your
own personal computer that can solve problems
and feel love.
It’s basically what I hope siri will be
by the next iphone.
But the brain ain’t nothing without the
spine.
It’s your spine that sends the motor signals
from your brain to your limbs so you can walk
and pat yourself on the back.
Thanks spine!
Sensory signals travel back up your spine
to your brain, so you can feel when you’re
getting a hug or a high five.
Way to go, spine!
The spine can even operate without the brain
in some cases.
The spine can store or learn reflexes.
When the doctor makes your knee jerk, or a
hockey goalie catches a puck going 100 miles
an hour, that’s all spine, baby.
Otherwise it would take too much time for
the brain to react and send the signal to
the limbs, and the puck would be in the net.
So because the spine does so much more than
prop you upright, it’s bad news when it
gets damaged.
The spine and the brain both exhibit neuroplasticity,
meaning they can adapt and rewire themselves
when they’re injured.
By the way, longtime viewers of the show know
when we say the word “neuroplasticity,”
the DNews drinking game has begun.
However the spine’s neuroplasticity is very
limited compared to the brain’s neuroplasticity.
If the damage is severe enough, glial scars
form that inhibit the regeneration of nerve
fibers or axons and communication with the
brain is cut off past that point.
But there’s been a breakthrough.
Derek Fidyka has been paralyzed from the chest
down since being stabbed in 2010.
Because our damaged central nervous system
doesn’t generate new axons, scientists basically
hacked the human body to restore Fidyka’s
spine.
They took Olfactory Ensheathing Glia, which
stimulate the growth of Olfactory Axons in
your nose, put them in his spine, and boom!
After just 6 months of 5 hours of exercise
and therapy 5 days a week, he can walk using
leg braces and parallel bars.
Ok it’s not instant gratification.
In fact it’s a lot of very hard work that’s
physically and emotionally exhausting.
But it’s worth it just to be able to walk
again, and to me the guy’s a hero.
He’s like, Axon Jackson.
So if you can walk, don’t take it for granted.
Be grateful and hug a spine today.
With the spine owner’s permission, obviously.
If you’d like to learn more about neuroplasticity,
Anthony covers that here.
in fact learning from that video will actually
make use of neuroplasticity.
What are some simple things your body does
you’re grateful for?
I’m grateful to my liver every time we do
a video involving neuroplasticity.
Let us know in the comments and thanks for
watching DNews…
Neuroplasticity